that's weird my pants rank I think I hit
puberty I'm well uh so you're like new
here right we got that in common okay
then uh I'll see you around this could
literally not get any weirder it can get
weirder I just washed my hands that's
why they're wet no other reason do
animals talk in this dimension cuz I
don't want to freak him out wherever I
go the wind follows and the wind
it smells like rain hey fellas sometimes
I let matches burn down to my fingertips
just to feel something anything time to
swing just like I taught you all right
watch and learn kid I'll quiz you later
we're a little team me is the teacher
who could still do it hey guys I'm from
another dimension I mean another and
other dimensions
how many more spider people are there my
name is penny Parker I'm from New York
in the year 31 45 it's a little freaking
like show you're gonna love this he's
not always about my money spider-man
spider-man I mean this guy swings in
once the day zip zap zop and his little
mask and answers to no one I love you
that's a copy why aren't you at school
whoa it's okay it's okay
miles get the bus ow is it the
earthquake our family doesn't run away
from things miles o units I want an APB
on a new spider-man you're not stopping
this not today like a cartoon can you
rewire a mainframe while being shot out
everybody acting anything in lorca miles
gotta go
gentlemen see you Friday
can you close off your feelings so you
don't get crippled by the moral
ambiguity of your violent actions
you